so i had that tweet that donald trump
pinned on twitter for a long time where
it was like the written house thing like
helped convince me to vote for trump
and
it that's like
like the left views it as like it's
proof of being far right or whatever
it's crazy though because it's this this
story with right now shows you that left
and right are meaningless other than you
either are an idiot who believes fake bs
or you care about facts
destiny for instance leftist streamer
yeah was like the clearest case of
self-defense i've ever seen yeah right
yeah
and then his argument with vosh vosh
said in the marvel movies good guys put
their guns down it's like what yeah no
no they don't and that's totally fake
and it was so horrific it was such an
abomination when they changed star wars
for example and made it so that han did
not oh right first that was the
stupidest thing ever obviously what
makes him a good character is that he's
conflicted is that he i don't think he
was conflicted he was like i'm going to
shoot this man he does he does bad
things right there's like
so well he was kind of a scoundrel yeah
which is a good thing about him and
that's the only i mean would leah have
fallen for the good guy no way well she
kissed her brother that was a little
weird of her
really a little bit strict oh just for
luck you know the funny thing about the
star wars when when when she kissed her
brother is that they have the force
right they have like strong in the force
so they had to have known right you know
when when when
yeah
wasn't it like with magnets you know
where they're like like they're gonna
hold on to each other
when he's like vader's already vader's
here already he can sense my presence or
whatever and then when vader's like
search your feelings or whatever you
know about whether he's your father oh
my goodness so there's no way but maybe
it's not maybe it's only if you're
looking for it you know if you're into
somebody you don't stop to think i need
to search the force for whether this is
my sister yeah so that's not going to be
your sister they have that app in
iceland yeah they do
yeah
oh really yeah yeah yeah yeah there's an
app in iceland where you can look up if
the person you're dating is actually
your cousin very small gene pool up
there yeah i can see that being uh
repurposed for a kink
well back to kyle rittenhouse um
no yeah this will be interesting well
it's insane too because this is another
reason why it's so
dangerous to have a dialogue surrounding
guns in a country where a large majority
of the citizens have never handled a gun
and most of the people on the other side
of the gun debate have never seen one in
person i think often times because
people don't realize
the unbelievable discipline which was
required for kyle to literally only hit
his targets like he is in an urban
environment being chased on by a mob and
he only hit the people who are trying to
attack him people think that weapons
function as they do in the films where
anyone can just hit whatever target they
want to shoot that's not easy it's not
easy
and it's it's most and this is one thing
that anyone who knows anything about
firearms will tell you when people ask
like why would you need 30 rounds why
would you need a 15-hour magazine and a
handgun well the reason is because most
of the time you're not going to hit your
target especially if you don't train
very often especially if you're an
average person you're not in the
military or something someone who's been
tactically trained or shoots every day
you're probably going to miss a good
amount and also it can take more than
one bullet to take a person down so the
the fact that this kid was able to with
precision hit only the people who were
trying to hurt him when he was being
chased down by an entire mob of people
is a testament
of adults is a testament to how
responsible he was he wasn't just out
there
shooting his gun out like a maniac he
only hit people who were a direct threat
to his life even though an entire mob
was chasing him down well that's why so
the judge said you can call them riders
looters and arsonists but not victims
right the the amount of misinformation
in this story it's it's mind-boggling
it's infuriating because i expect it
when it comes to politics yeah but this
is so crazy man
go on twitter
and look at like what these these these
progressive tick tockers or tick tackers
are saying about it
and they're like a white supremacist
mass murderer who took a gun across
state lines it's like that is none of it
is true it's not a matter of time
too is shortly after that i think it was
in what was it september
of 2020
um the biden campaign came out with an
ad where they called rittenhouse a white
nationalist a white nashville yeah they
could just say that about anybody biden
called him that biden said that in a
campaign ad and the family came out and
said we're going to sue you i don't know
what happened with that but when you
have the man who becomes president
making up lies to win political
elections lies about a teenager lies
about to try to damage the republicans
he's trying to protect his community
yeah and himself well and it's funny too
one of the reasons one of the most
obvious tells from the gecko that this
was not the kind of mass shooting
situation the left was trying to make it
out to be is people on the left were
actually referring to gun laws that they
thought were broken every single time a
shooting occurs they pretend that there
were no laws in place to prevent it
because then they have to acknowledge
the fact that whatever new laws are put
into place are just going to be
disobeyed by any psychopath who wants to
murder people anyway and so with written
house there saying he traveled to a
different state with a gun which is
illegal first of all that's not even
true but if it was if you really think
someone's a mass murderer you're not all
that concerned with the regulations they
broke transporting their gun it's all
they got exactly it's all they had
this is it
it's crazy like
man the the
it's been getting bad
you know i know i know i go civil war
and all stuff but i'm like dude it is
really bad so i follow a bunch of
progressive youtubers and stuff and just
to see the amount of fake news they
peddle i realize something today because
like a lot of them i watch they don't
have sources
or they'll use broken sources they won't
seek out they'll find a source that has
the information they prefer of course
and then they'll show that as their
source like slate.com and huffingtonpost
and i use cnn as often as i can i do i
do use dailymail fairly often but i try
to use cnn i try to use cbs i try to use
nbc and then i'm always fact checking
and trying to be like are there are
there
whenever i'm looking at a story i'll try
and find like four different versions of
the same story and then go through them
and see what their sources to make sure
that they're not doing closed-loop
sourcing
i think that makes a lot of sense to do
it that way because otherwise you're
just not sure who's reporting off of
what and where they got their
information
so if i can verify something i choose to
use cnn because i think it's funny yeah
i'm like and use their own sources
against them 100 well if cena gets it
right they deserve to be used the source
also true
on those rare occasions and more
importantly when they're like tim paul
made up this story about written house
like that's that's the name of times
yeah so i tweeted
uh that people were tweeting about the
alec baldwin thing and they were like
you know alec baldwin did nothing wrong
and they said kyle rittenhouse should go
to prison and then i said alec baldwin
was a producer on the film who was
handed a load weapon didn't check
pointed at him and pulled the trigger
kyle rittenhouse
was
you know defending was defending a bunch
of businesses from rioters who fled
after being attacked trying to put out a
fire trying to put a fire on us and
pushing it towards a gas station and
only fired when fired upon and i get
these leftists like that never happened
no one fired at him and i'm like the new
york times reported that it's the new
york times so i pull up the new york
times i show the photo where it shows
the circle it says muzzle flash and then
i paste it i'm like there's the image
here's the link and they're like oh
please if you go frame by frame you can
make anything up and there were there
were journalists on the ground covering
that stuff we've had it all incredible
yeah and we were all watching that it
was all it was so clear
dude if
there was great coverage of that yeah
people people made a good point the
other day if written house gets uh
convicted there'll be riots if he's
acquitted there will be riots and it's
not gonna be from the right of course
like the left is gonna write no matter
what because if they do convict him he's
not gonna get
the worst possible charges probably i
mean for a while i was saying life but
after seeing this judge i like this
well yeah exactly here's the thing part
of why this is such an important battle
for them is because they want people to
be terrified of the mob and they want
you to know that if you defend yourself
you're going to be punished for it and
so if this kid goes down simply for
defending himself the message that sends
to the american public is if there are
people in your community burning down
businesses and attacking innocent people
you mind your business or if you're the
person who they want to kill you let
them kill you because if you don't we'll
destroy your life anyway
so the thing about written house really
is that
if he hadn't defended himself if he had
allowed the mob
to kill him as 33 people were killed
this past summer none of us would know
his name right but because he defended
himself he's front page news we would
know his name we might yeah but the
average person wouldn't be talking about
it if the people who killed him when
their trial date come up that came up
that wouldn't be a news story they
wouldn't be pushing it as hard as
they're pushing the written house story
the media wouldn't be talking about it
they're pushing the berry story the
ahmad our berry story the young man oh
right
killed in georgia by um who's a black
man killed in georgia by three
white guys in a pickup truck he was
jogging he was jogging and he was
driving inside a house he was under
construction he was jogging inside a
house under construction right yeah
um
yeah so that was another sort of like uh
what in boots right
was this double check i need to double
check on this yeah i think he was
wearing boots but the the mob has to use
might because they have no moral
authority at all and so they have to use
shame and all of those things that's the
only way that they have power there
isn't there's an occupying force in our
culture and government that is
represents a fringe faction of
ideologies
and it's because of the cowardice of so
many people that they're able to get
away with what they do exactly and these
mobs are their militant wing i i am so i
have to say i'm so intrigued by this
judge by him saying this before the
trial even gets underway what is he
thinking what is he trying to convey
because he's being surprisingly based
which is
well you know what he said he said that
if the defense could back up their
claims that these were arsonists rioters
and looters then they could for sure
call them that they just have to back it
up which i think is um
pretty possible to do they were
literally trying to set a gas station on
fire that night right in canada
yeah the prosecutor argued they were
just trying to obstruct a road with a
flaming dumpster and the judge is like
that's okay yeah the judge goes he's
like
he's like excuse me it's just arson come
on as if there's a zone where that's
acceptable
and they're like well you know he wasn't
yeah this is this is what we we have to
look forward to well there was another
man too who i don't think it's in
kenosha we reported on it at
post-millennial mia cathell wrote about
it at length um there was a man who was
defending his shop and his elderly
father against a mob of looters and this
man shot one of the looters who was
trying to break into the shop he was
then um condemned vilified mobbed online
all of that stuff for being a racist
because the man he shot was black he was
simply he was defending his shop against
these people
and he later killed himself whoa oh my
because it was so traumatizing and
horrible
nobody says his name i can't even
remember his name which is
horrible there's a story out of philly
that never got really big play at all
because there was no interest from
anybody to cover it but during the
height of the riots i there was a local
gun stories to go to and the guy told me
this is crazy he told me that
they got a warning from the atf
that people were going to try and loot
gun stores during the riots right
later on
i heard a news story
that three guys tried breaking into a
philly gun store and one of them i think
one of them was shot and killed and like
someone may have may have been injured i
can't remember but
i put two and two together i was like
whoa
i remember so what happened was the guy
was sleeping in his gun shop that's
right
atf probably called him
told him because the other gun shop told
me he was also sleeping in a store right
and then he's sitting there armed and
someone breaks in and bam
jeez no one no that's a way to save
lives is to prevent people from stealing
your guns yeah yeah but no no to a
person thought it was going to be a good
story probably to be like hey look what
happened and the left certainly didn't
want to say hey the black lives matter
people are trying to steal guns now oh
gosh right there is that video though
where they break into a gun store and
then just start taking everything have
you seen that i haven't seen that dude
it was crazy last year can you believe
it's been almost two years since we've
been under uh we've been living under
fascism i didn't realize i had no idea
that's crazy right when would you say
the fascism started the lockdowns march
13th 2020. yeah is that it the dates so
we're about a year and a half in that's
when new york city's school closed
school is not
not going to work available thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you